devastating bombings by radical
Islamists kill hundreds on Easter in Sri
Lanka fallout from the mullah report
continues and Democrats opened fire on
each other for the 2020 nomination I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
a lot of news most of it horrific over
the weekend we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about my
all-time favorite underdog story in the
business world I'm talking of course
about movement watches founded on the
belief that style should not break the
bank they've sold almost 2 million
watches worldwide by bringing quality
designs at fair prices here is my
favorite new style check this one out
look at that it's minimalist it's nice
right I mean you get it for a price that
is not going to break the bank they've
got new styles that come all the time
and I received compliments on this stuff
all the time I've got movement watches
for my wife or my parents for my in-laws
that they really aren't spectacularly
nice and they're what really makes them
great is again they're not gonna tell
you how many steps that you're taking
they're just gonna tell you the time in
the classiest minimalist fashion
movement watches are all about looking
good while keeping it simple and you
folks know that I'm all about supporting
ground up entrepreneurs work hard for
what they want which is one of the
reasons I love movement they're a true
success story makes wearing their
products much more meaningful they came
up and made a name for themselves in one
of the most established markets in the
world and reached exponential growth
which is amazing for such a young team
movement watches start at just 95 bucks
so if you're looking at 400 bucks for
the same quality from a traditional bear
and you are wasting your time you get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t-dot-com
slash Shapiro's movements launching new
sights new styles on their site all the
time check out their latest MVM
t-dot-com slash shapiro MVM t.com slash
imperial join the movement and when you
use that slash apparel get 15% off all
right so the big news over the weekend
obviously are these devastating bombings
in Sri Lanka according to the the asam's
France press the AFP Sri Lanka said on
Monday it believed a local Islamist
extremist group was behind deadly
suicide bomb blast that killed nearly
300 people as an ordered a national
state of emergency beginning on midnight
government spokesman Raja sir Sena
Rodney said investigators were looking
at whether the national foul Heath Jamaa
ntj group had international support for
the deadly Easter Sunday attacks on
churches and luxury hotels so far it's
one see four people have been arrested
in connection with the attacks this is a
large
coordinated attack apparently there were
seven suicide bombers who detonated near
simultaneously in different spots no
details were given about the people who
are actually arrested yet little is
known about this particular group but
documents seen by the AFP show Sri Lanka
she issued a warning on April 11th so
not very long ago at all within the last
couple of weeks saying a foreign
intelligence agency had reported that
the group was planning attacking
churches and the Indian High Commission
the group had previously only been
linked to vandalizing Buddhist statues
so all sorts of Tolerance and wonder
from the radical Muslim world again sir
is an errata new set up the deadly
attacks we don't see that only a small
organization in this country can do all
that they think that this was created by
outside support as well they say we are
now investigating the international
support for them and their other links
how they produced the suicide bombers
here how they produced bombs like this
the death toll from Sunday's attacks
rose dramatically on Monday to 290
including dozens of foreigners it's the
worst atrocity since the country's civil
war ended a decade ago more than 500
people were injured in the assault that
sauce suicide bombers hit three high-end
hotels popular with foreign tourists and
three churches unleashing a carnage in
Colombo and beyond to additional blasts
were triggered as security forces
carried out raids searching for the
suspects presumably these places had
been booby-trapped as well when folks
look at the casualty statistics in in
areas like this what they tend to often
do is look at the deaths and not at the
injured well knowing some people who
have been injured in terrorist attacks
the injuries are often devastating and
life demolishing in nearly the same way
that in that a k-i a would be in nearly
the same way that being killed on scene
would be I mean people lose limbs people
are mentally crippled from from these
attacks if they're hit in the head
people lose years off their life span I
mean it's so so pretend that this is
just about the 290 dead obviously the
500 injured plays into this as well
police also found 87 bomb detonators at
a Colombo bus station as well so
obviously all of this is extraordinarily
scary and devastating the government has
announced that the victims families and
the injured will receive some government
compensation they say that they'll
compensate all the people who died which
is about a hundred thousand rupees for
their funeral expenses so a hundred
thousand rupees is not all that much
money unfortunately but you know the
government is going to do what they're
gonna spend a thousand dollars fourteen
hundred dollars in American currency the
Health Minister has said that
authorities were warned full two weeks
before the attacks they had the names of
the attack
but that information was not shared with
the Prime Minister the president had the
portfolio has the portfolio of Defense
is the only country where when the Prime
Minister summons the Security Council
they don't assemble Minister Sarah not
and he said we're not trying to evade
responsibility but these are the facts
we were surprised to see these reports
so it looks a lot sort of like the
Chinese wall that was that was created
between the FBI and CIA in the United
States prior to 9/11
it looks like the Health Ministry
apparently not only knew about the
attacks they knew the names of the
potential attackers but the Prime
Minister didn't actually have that
information and the president the Prime
Minister won't talking to one another so
obviously internal government issues
there now there is something odd about
the reaction to these attacks there's
something very odd about the reaction to
these attacks so in the aftermath of the
Christchurch attacks in New Zealand
everyone came forth and they said it's
time to re-examine and it's time to
examine the relationship between white
supremacy and Islamophobia between the
slaughter of innocents at a mosque in
Christchurch New Zealand
and the evils of white supremacy and
that was perfectly appropriate the evils
of white supremacy are indeed evil and
looking at white supremacist groups and
looking at the evil they perpetrate is
well worth looking into
I don't know a good-hearted person who
avoided this conversation we did I think
2 or 3 full episodes on exactly this
issue after Christchurch and yet oddly
and strangely folks on the Left seem
unwilling or unable to acknowledge that
what happened here was a radical
Islamist terror attack so Hillary
Clinton tweeted this out quote this was
in the aftermath of Christchurch in the
aftermath of Christchurch I won I want
to contrast compare and contrast Hillary
Clinton's tweets on Christchurch and
what just happened in Sri Lanka and
Christchurch was awful and it was evil
and 50 Muslims were killed about six
times as many people were killed in Sri
Lanka on Sunday during Easter which is
in fact a holy day so this is a pretty
apples to apples comparison Hillary
Clinton tweeted this in the aftermath of
the Christchurch attacks quote my heart
breaks for New Zealand and the global
Muslim community we must continue to
fight the perpetuation and normalization
of Islamophobia and racism in all its
forms white supremacist terrorists must
be condemned by leaders everywhere their
murderous hatred must be stopped a
contrast that which is a very strong
statement about the victims right it's
it's it's states who the victims are it
states who the perpetrators are and in
states that their ideology must
faut contrast that with Hillary
Clinton's comments after nearly 300
people are murdered while going to
church during Easter in Sri Lanka so
here's what she said about Sri Lanka
quote on this holy weekend for many
faiths we must stand united against
hatred and violence I'm praying for
everyone affected by today's horrific
attack on Easter worshippers and
travelers in Sri Lanka okay so do you
notice the difference no clear
explanation of who is targeted Easter
worshippers not Christians Easter
worshippers also a holy weekend for many
faiths well I would be the other faith
for which this is a holy weekend right
this is Passover so this is Pesach for
me I would be the other faith for which
this is a holy weekend it's Easter and
it's Passover also we weren't targeted
this weekend there are lots of other
weekend's on which Jews are targeted
there are lots of days on which Jews are
targeted that are not holy days this was
not one of those days this is a day in
which Christians were targeted in Sri
Lanka this was an attack specifically on
Christians not about a holy weekend for
many faiths it was specifically about
Easter it was not about Pesach it was
not about Passover when she said we must
stand united against hatred and violence
so now it's just broad scale hatred and
violence it's so funny when no hen Omar
says something anti-semitic then the
Democrats condemn it racism fully across
the spectrum when a white supremacist
does something evil would condemn white
supremacy so if it's a form of evil if
it's an evil ideology that kills lots of
people but it's not white supremacy then
we just condemn evil generally but it's
one when it's white supremacy we condemn
white supremacy specifically we should
condemn white supremacy specifically
this is not an argument to whitewash
white supremacy or Waterdown criticism
of white supremacy the opposite it is an
argument to continue to focus in on that
and also to focus in at least a little
on radical Islam which is responsible
for exponentially more deaths worldwide
than white supremacy is I'll give you
the statistics in just a second I mean
that's weed from Hillary that contrast
is really stunning on this holy weekend
of many faiths to must stand united
against hatred and violence
what kind of hatred day and any clues
you have any clues well it turns out one
of the Bombers and one of the guys
arrested one of the planners of this his
name is mohamed mohamed do we have any
clues as to who this may have been it
turns out that there was an Islamist
group but the government knew about and
has already taken credit for this any
clues at all guys
or is it just generalized hatred and
violence the same sort of hatred and
violence as when my son pushes down my
daughter like what kind of hatred and
violence are we talking about any
specifics okay Brock Obama did the same
thing here's what he did in the
aftermath of Christchurch Michelle and I
send our condolences to the people of
New Zealand we grieve with you and the
Muslim community all of us must stand
against hatred in all of its form so he
grieves with the people of Christchurch
and the Muslim community more generally
here's Barack Obama in the aftermath of
what just happened in Sri Lanka he
tweeted out the attacks on tourists and
Easter worshippers in Sri Lanka are an
attack on humanity not on Muslims
everywhere on humanity generally Onate
devoted to love Redemption and renewal
we pray for the victims and stand with
the people of Sri Lanka is it forbidden
to say Christians are we not allowed to
say the words Christians Obama's is not
as bad as Hillary's by the way Hillary's
is much worse
Hillary comes forth and she says we have
to fight Islamophobia in all of its
forms and white supremacy in all of its
forms and then radical Muslims go and
kill a bunch of Christians at church on
Easter Sunday and it's hatred and
violence are really bad guys they're
really I can't really get more specific
than that don't know how to get more
specific you know Obama you can at least
make the argument that by Easter
worshippers like I don't think the
Easter worshippers part of this
silliness is the worst part of it I
think that it is indicative of a failure
on the part of many people on the left
to single out Christians as victims
because that does not fit within the
intersectional hierarchy in the United
States the intersectional hierarchy for
the left is the suggestion that we know
just based on our own experiences based
on anecdotal evidence we know who are
the most victimized groups in America
those victimized groups are transgender
people and black people and Muslims
those are the people who are most
victimized in America nevermind the hate
crime statistics let's say that I'm per
capita basis in the United States Jews
are the most victimized and nevermind
the global statistics that say on a
global basis Christians are the most
victimized group in in on planet Earth
there's a Pew report from June of 2018
that specifically says this this is not
me just making up that Christians are
the most victimized religious group on
planet earth they are according to Pew
Research Center the Center's report on
religious harassment in 2016 found that
Christians were harassed in 144
countries up from 128 the year before
the Muslims were harassed in 142
countries from 125 in 2015 by the way
that's kind of astonishing considering
that there are many many more officially
Muslim countries than there
officialy Christian countries on planet
earth there's 50 odd officially Muslim
countries on the planet and there are
how many officially Christian countries
are there a couple in Eastern Europe
that I believe are officially Christian
but they say there's a state religion in
any case the report says Christians and
Muslims have typically been harassed in
the largest numbers of countries around
the world those two groups are the
largest religious groups in the world
they have substantial populations in
more countries than other smaller and
less geographically dispersed religious
groups get some more information on this
in just one second first let's talk
about how you send your packages every
day well no one really has time to go to
the post office in fact this reminds me
that I have an unpaid parking ticket
from the last time I went to the post
office which I'll have to handle after
the show you're too busy to go to the
post office you don't have time for the
traffic you know money for the parking
tickets instead you need stamps com1 the
most popular time saving tools for small
businesses stamps.com
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money with discounts you can't
get even at the post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices and
online seller shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps comm can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in the mailbox it is
indeed that simple with stamps commie at
five cents off every first class stamp
up to 40% off Priority Mail not to
mention it is a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters stamps
that comes a no brainer it saves you
time it saves you money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already used stamps calm
right now my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and digital scale with
no long term commitment just go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page type in code
Shapiro that Sam's calm and answer
Shapiro that special awesome deal we use
stamps calm in the office for a reason
and you should too like most small
businesses we want to save money stamps
calm allows us to do that and saves us
time as well stamps calm and use code
Shapiro so as we say the Pew Research
Center found that Christians are in fact
the most persecuted religious group on
planet earth not on a per capita basis
but on a generalized
basis it is also true that while we have
spent enormous attention focusing on
white supremacy here in the
and again I think every iota of that is
deserved if you are going to compare the
deaths and the carnage attributable to
white supremacy to the deaths and
carnage attributable to radical Islam
the numbers are not even remotely close
they're not remotely close the only way
that you can get too close to parity in
any sense is if you look specifically
and only within the West if you look
specifically and only within the West
then it looks like white supremacist
terror attacks are somewhere near on par
since 2003 with Islamist terrorist
attacks in the West although Islamist
terrorist attacks in the West have been
responsible for vastly more deaths there
are a lot of white supremacist terror
attacks that don't end in as many mass
casualty incidents so you have white
supremacy terrorist attacks in places
like the Pittsburg tree of life
synagogue where I believe 11 people were
killed or Christ Church where 50 people
were killed well every year we have a
couple of Islamic incidents where 50
people are killed at a Christmas market
in Berlin and this sort of stuff happens
on a fairly regular basis but if you
look worldwide and Sri Lanka is not in
the West Sri Lanka is not a European
country if you look worldwide radical
Islamic terrorism is a significantly
greater threat than white supremacy it
is not close it is not even remotely
close okay I'll give you an example and
it does demonstrate how the media
coverage here is extraordinarily skewed
and almost darkly funny because of how
extraordinarily skewed it is there's an
article in US News and World Report
called globally terrorism deaths are on
the decline this is from December of
2018 just a few months ago and it talks
about the sixth global terrorism index
which was published on by the Institute
for economics and peace an independent
non-profit think tank based in Australia
and it looked at the number of terrorist
deaths across the world it found that in
2017 there were eighteen thousand eight
hundred and fourteen deaths globally
according to the study that was a twenty
seven percent drop according to the
study now in just a second I'm gonna
give you the actual breakdown in how
many of those were white supremacist
deaths so as we say the deaths
attributable to terrorism in 2017
eighteen thousand eight hundred and
fourteen globally according to the
Institute for economics and peace hey
how many of those were due to white
supremacy okay so listen to how the
media cover this this is in US News and
World Report the
a far-right political terrorism is a
growing concern in North America and
Western Europe according to the findings
while the UK Spain Finland Sweden in
Austria were the only countries to
experience increases in deaths from
terrorism in Western Europe both Canada
and the United States experienced
increases in total deaths in North
America far-right groups and individuals
caused 66 deaths and launched 127
attacks in the regions between 2013 and
2017 so they spend several full
paragraphs discussing the threat of
far-right political terrorism in the
West again that's fine this report says
that in 2017 alone globally there nearly
19,000 deaths from terrorism 19,000
between 2013 and 2017 there were 66
deaths from white supremacist terrorism
in the West compared to 19,000 in 2017
alone globally and yet the media will
spend vastly more time talking about
white supremacist terrorism and then
we'll spend talking about radical
Islamic terrorism why is that it's not
because the numbers it's because it
reinforces a narrative the narrative is
that the true threat to the West and the
true threat across the world really is
white supremacist evil and in the West
particularly if we're gonna look at
white supremacy white supremacy is a
threat again this is me for the 90th
time this show saying that we should
take white supremacy seriously as a
person who has full-time security thanks
to threats from white supremacist is a
person by security at their shul
basically thanks to threats from white
supremacist let me suggest that we
should focus on white supremacy but the
media's unwillingness to even say
radical Islamic terrorism when an
obvious radical Islamic terror attack
occurs somewhere else in the world or at
home on American soil is pretty
astonishing and indicative of a
worldview that is perverse if you cannot
label specific evil by the specific type
when it happens because you are afraid
of the consequences you're part of
enshrining that evil if yours that the
left says this all the time if you can't
label Christ Church or white supremacist
terror attack then you are lending cover
to people who commit those sorts of
terror attacks I think on a
philosophical level there are some truth
to this if that is true I think that on
a philosophical level if you refuse to
acknowledge that the Orlando pulse
attack or the San Bernardino terrorist
attack with radical Islamic terror
attacks if you say that what happened in
Sri Lanka was due to generalized racism
and violence generalized hatred and
violence then you are providing cover to
some pretty terrible people you ought to
be able to name evil for what it is you
ought to be able to label evil for what
it is so then we can determine how we
ought to distribute our resources in
fighting that evil and we also ought to
be able to suggest that two threats are
present at the same time and not in
equal numbers this is why when people
were criticizing Johan Omar for not
taking terrorism seriously they were
correct
ohana Maher does not take terrorism
seriously representative Omar had
suggested in a column in 2017 which i
think is worse than any other thing that
she's written other than a letter in
2016 or she tried to have a judge let
Isis recruits off early because there
were victims of what she called American
marginalization in 2017 she wrote a
piece suggesting that America was
founded in genocide and slavery and in
order to misdirect away from our
foundations in genocide and slavery we
therefore focused on international
terrorism that provides cover for a
radical ideology that does create
violence why can't we walk and chew gum
at the same time it's one thing to say
we don't pay enough attention to white
supremacy I would argue that is
certainly not the case now it is another
to argue that we should ignore one type
of terrorism in favor of another type of
terrorism and those tweets from from
Hillary Clinton are pretty damned
telling you should be able to label this
stuff for what it is and if you cannot
you should be able to explain why it is
that you cannot label these things for
what they are turns out there are lots
of different types of victims and lots
of different types of perpetrators and
those perpetrators commit crimes at
wildly variant rates and particularly
when you are talking about problems
abroad and violence abroad radical Islam
has bloody borders radical Islam does
create the vast majority of terrorism
worldwide it is not even close it is
simply not closed
alrighty meanwhile the other big story
over the weekend was of course all the
fallout from the Muller report so last
week you want to listen to my total take
on the Mullen report listen to our shows
on Thursday and Friday because I had
read the entire report by the time we
did the show on Thursday and I broke it
down on Thursday and then I broke it
down in eight specific ways from eight
eight angles on Friday my bottom line in
the Muller report is that there's no
collusion obviously the report itself
the first half the report is basically
an empty vessel there's not much there
other than a lot of smoke with
various members of the Trump campaign
who are sort of hobnobbing with Russians
in incompetent ways but that never
getting passed up the chain then trumped
our meeting turns out to be a big
nothing it turns out that virtually all
of the smoke turned into no fire it was
a waste of time it was a giant waste of
time in the original theory of the
Mullen report and of James Comey and of
Andrew McCabe and of and of James
clapper and of John Brennan their
original theory that Donald Trump was
somehow in cahoots with Putin in 2016
that was a bunch of nonsense that was
finding number one finding number two is
that there was no proof sufficient to
prove obstruction of justice because
President Trump was basically walking
around the White House and fulminating
and fuming over all of the wrongs done
to him by the Muller report and so he's
walking around telling people to fire
people and send letters and lie to the
press and none of that is good stuff but
none of that is obstruction of justice
he could have fired any of those people
and it wouldn't be obstruction of
justice in a technical criminal sense
maybe it was impeachable it wouldn't
have been obstruction of justice in any
criminal sense now the Trump
administration continues to come out and
suggest that the model report got it
wrong now at this point if you're the
Trump administration what you'd probably
want to do is just say look Muller
family found no prosecution is taking
place the American people are ready to
move on Rudy Giuliani however is
challenging some aspects of the reports
of Rudy Giuliani is the president's
lawyer and he says yeah you know some of
the things in the report are playing out
our plane falls this is a prosecutor's
document 400 pages the prosecutors view
and then a prosecutor which I think
people would grant had a lot of people
that was somewhat biased against the
president I don't know that everybody
would grant that but well I think your
opinion but in any event a lot of things
are left out a lot of things have false
oh I shouldn't say a lot of things some
things are false
a lot of things are questionable it's
clear that they tried very very hard to
create a case that the president was
involved in Russian whatever couldn't do
it they tried a hundred different ways
okay and that was also true of
obstruction of justice the most
exonerating part of this report is how
when you read that second half of the
report it is obvious that Muller and
Millers prosecutors really do not like
Trump it is really obvious that they are
trying to draw the worst possible
conclusions from what is by all
available evidence just evidence of a
volatile and shallow personality problem
the president has I mean this is his
volatile behavior is well known to
everyone this is not anything new the
attempt to draw some sort of nefarious
conclusion about him obstructing justice
or shutting down the mellow report when
the Moller report as we know reached a
terminus they reached a conclusion is a
pretty absurd thing well the left is now
saying well we have the material to
impeach we'll talk about that in just
one second so what they're saying is
that well Trump did not testify and
members of his administration were were
declaring that they didn't know things
the idea was that that presumably if
they'd all talked if we've been able to
get to the bottom of this there would
have been something criminal and
impeachable well that's that in just one
second
first it's springtime it's the time of
year when seeds grow into flowers and
you grow up financially at least your
family needs protection if something
happens to you so grow up that means you
need life insurance thankfully policy
genius makes it easy to get the
financial security without the growing
pains policy genius is the easy way to
buy life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find your best price once
you apply the policy genius team will
handle all the paperwork and the red
tape no Commission's no hidden fees just
financial protection and peace of mind
no strings attached policy genius
doesn't just simplify life insurance
they also make it easy to compare and
buy home insurance auto insurance and
disability insurance so the next time
you stop to smell the roses pull out
your phone head on over to policy genius
calm then you can get back to enjoying
your life because who really wants to
spend all their time thinking about life
insurance just get it taken care of and
then you don't have to worry about it
ever again and make it the top of your
list get it done in two minutes over a
policy genius calm policy genius spring
is here and kick it off by nipping life
insurance in the bud and ensuring that
your family is taken care of make sure
that you're not buried in a pauper's
grave and if you should be hit by a
truck tomorrow that your family has some
money to take care of them go over to
policy genius comm right now and get it
taken care of come on just being at all
all right meanwhile as we say the the
left is focusing in on the Muller Report
as the basis not for criminality but for
impeachment and they are clinging to a
couple of different lines of argument
line of argument number one is that
while the report found no collusion
there's still collusion this is so empty
and so foolish but listen Adam Schiff
still has to defend himself mean repres
chef from California has spent the last
two years claiming that he has secret
knowledge that Muller would get Trump
that in the end
Mellor would uncover the secret meeting
in a Russian hotel in which prostitutes
peed all over the President of the
United States as he shouted I hate
Hillary and then he went in the other
room clean himself off and signed an
agreement with Vladimir Putin to build
Trump Tower Moscow in return for in
return for giving some sort of favors to
Vlad as what Adam Schiff has sort of
been suggesting all along and the steel
dossier is probably true everything all
the stuff and if it's not there's other
information that's definitely gonna come
out we kept hearing this and we kept
hearing over and over Muller has
information you do not I thought well
that's true mother does have information
that I do not but it turns out he didn't
have that much information I did not
which is kind of a problem for him Adam
Schiff continues to maintain however
that there is still evidence of
collusion what a joke this guy is the
fact that he's still being treated with
seriousness it speaks to the same media
that treated Michael avenatti with
serious seriousness for years and
started promoting him as a as a
potential 2020 candidate here's the Adam
Schiff still making excuses for the fact
that he's a liar what I talked about
evidence of collusion in plain sight I
used those words in plain sight and I
pointed to the meetings in Trump Tower
that Don jr. and Kushner and mana Ford
took and what more clear intent to
collude could you have than the Russians
offering dirt on Hillary Clinton as part
of what was described as an effort to
help mr. Trump in the campaign and Don
jr. saying if it's what you say I would
love it now I don't know how you find
more abundant evidence of an intent to
clewd than that okay well I mean the
intents of collude you'd actually have
to I don't know have intent to collude
and all of the plain sight evidence that
he was like calling on WikiLeaks to
release stuff or the Don jr. met with a
lawyer to get up oh that is not
collusion that is accepting Oppo you
know who else accepted Oppo about their
opponent from foreign sources during the
campaign that would be Hillary Clinton
maybe fusion GPS which accepted Oppo
from a foreign source namely from
Christopher Steele who it turns out was
not some high-ranking spy he was a hack
who put together cobbled together
a terrible piece of Apple research that
the FBI then accepted as the basis for
things like a FISA warrant Ashton
over at Daily wire my site she has a
great piece today talking about how the
New York Times has finally acknowledged
that the steel dossier might actually
not be all that great
she says the salacious and
uncorroborated dossier compiled by
ex-british intelligence officer
Christopher Steele was used by the media
to justify its endless attacks on
President Trump and accused him of
treason dossier was never anything more
than Apple research paid for by fusion
GPS and not even good Apple research at
that Steele reported rumors in gossip
including some internet comments to
bolster his report what wasn't
corroborated was downright two bunks by
Special Counsel Robert Muller's report
including the allegations that trump's
attorney former attorney Michael Cohen
went to Prague to meet with the Russians
now after two years of using the dossier
to perpetuate the collusion narrative
the New York Times has finally
acknowledged what those was not
parroting the collusion delusion have
known for years the dossier was
garbaggio The Times reported quote the
release on Thursday of the report by the
special counsel Robert a smaller the
third underscored what had grown clearer
for months and while many Trump aides
had welcomed contact with the Russians
some of the most sensational claims in
the dossier appeared to be false and
others were impossible to prove mr.
Muller's report contained over a dozen
passing references to the documents
claims but no overall assessments of why
so much did not check out now the
dossier is going to be subjected to two
inquiries one from the Geo J's Inspector
General and one from congressional
Republicans the FBI according to The
Times appears to have been suspicious of
the dossier since early 2017 that was
right around the time the media outlets
reported on the existence of the dossier
and BuzzFeed published the unverified
document in a breach of journalistic
ethics without checking out any of it
and so the fact that the FBI doubted the
dossiers credibility was never part of
the story instead media outlets like The
Times spent years talking to sources
claiming Muller had evidence supporting
claims in the dossier so pretty funny
that the New York Times has finally
acknowledged but Democrats will not and
so they continue to say that impeachment
is on the table now this puts them in a
box because the American people are not
interested in impeachment by polling
data a majority of Americans want to
move beyond this only 39% of Americans
say that they want further investigation
on all this that would be the hardcore
anti Trump base the vast majority of
Americans not interested in more of this
we've spent 25 million dollars in two
years and billions of dollars in free
media coverage on a nonsense issue that
never had any verifiability to it
aren't we done already like at a certain
point don't you cut your losses
but according to Democrats the answer is
never we will never cut our losses so
Jerry Nadler Democrat from New York he
says listen all of this stuff is
impeachable maybe we'll think about
impeachment this is impeachable
yeah I do I do think that this if proven
if proven which hasn't been proven yet
some of this if proven some of this
would be impeachable yes all right
obstruction of justice if proven would
be impeachable and you're gonna go about
to see if you can prove it well we're
gonna see where the facts lead us it was
not provable it was not proved in what
we'll see where the facts lead us you
guys were a lot you were buying Botev
candles of mullah or five minutes ago
and then when he didn't recommend
prosecution you say well maybe he's
wrong maybe it turns out that he's wrong
all along
amazing amazing stuff and then of course
you have nutty Maxine Waters who says
yeah you know let's impeach of course
she was saying let's impeach even if he
wasn't guilty of collusion just because
she doesn't like him now if we're going
to talk about public officials who
should have been impeached long ago
Maxine Waters who's one of the corrupt
most corrupt members of Congress
allegations that when she was on the
House Financial Services Committee a
dozen years ago she was funneling money
to a bank in which her husband was in
was an investor Maxine Waters says that
Trump should be impeached why because
the auntie Maxine doesn't like him she
does however like the LA uprising not
not the LA riots she calls it the la
uprising she's the like Maxine Waters I
have been calling for his impeachment
for a long time because I understood
very clearly who this man is how he
conducted himself during his campaign
and the kind of information that we
learned about him even before Moeller
came on board the fact of the matter is
I think that when you look at this
report you can see that there's enough
information there not only on
obstruction of justice but also on
collusion or conspiracy whatever you
want to call it to move forward with
impeachment on this president yeah
they're just gonna continue with this
over and over they're not going to stop
and so all of these impeachment minded
folks are gonna continue to push they're
going to suggest over and over that
impeachment is still on the table go for
it guys you want this all you all you
because the revelation of the report is
not that President Trump is a volatile
human did you not know that President
Trump was volatile humans you have eyes
and ears do you have sensory organs are
you unaware that President Trump is a
volatile human who does volatile things
and says silly things and yells at
people and treat his employees badly
where have you been
he became famous on a show where he
fired people he became famous by cut by
posing for the cover of Playboy magazine
Donald Trump basically bankrupted the
USFL like I mean there's nothing there's
nothing he bankrupted his own casino in
Atlantic City like what exactly are you
are you suggesting we did not know about
Donald Trump at this point that's I
think why so many people are off-put by
tweets like senator Mitt Romney so
Romney who everyone felt did not fight
Barack Obama with the alacrity the
President Trump fought Hillary Clinton
that he left some an ammo in the closet
he tweeted out in the aftermath of the
Mullen report senator Romney quote it is
good news that there was insufficient
evidence to charge the President of the
United States with having conspired with
foreign adversary or with having
obstructed justice the alternative would
have taken us through a wrenching
process with the potential for
constitutional crisis the business of
government can move on even so I am
sickened at the extent and pervasiveness
of dishonesty and misdirection by
individuals in the highest office of the
land including the president I'm also
appalled that among other things fellow
citizens worked in a campaign for
president welcoming help from Russia
including information that had been
illegally obtained that none of them
acted to inform American law enforcement
and that the campaign chairman was
actively promoting Russian interests in
Ukraine reading the report is a sobering
revelation of how far we have strayed
from the aspirations and principles of
the founders not an ideological level I
don't really disagree with much that
Romney says there but the angle is
totally wrong hey this we we knew all
this stuff these criticisms were
perfectly appropriate for two years when
we found out about George papadopolis
when we found out about the Trump Tower
meeting and when we found out about home
Anna for all of these things we're
perfectly appropriate then but that was
not the breaking news the breaking news
of the report is not all the stuff we
already knew it's all the stuff that we
didn't and all the stuff that we didn't
know basically just suggests that the
president is volatile and the president
is mean to people and the president
yells a lot and the his visor stop him
from doing dumb things and also most
importantly that there was no
obstruction of justice that's where this
license of the story was not Trump being
Trump the story was the media were
proved to be what they are the story was
Democrats were proved to be what they
are right that was the revelation the
Democrats were lying when they said they
had extra information that the media
were lying when they suggested that
there was far more to come that the
media proclaiming that Robert Muller is
going to end Trump's presidency that
that was a bunch of nonsense
for two years and that there are
motivated players in the space hey that
was the revelation so Romney can make
those criticisms I think a lot of those
criticisms are fair I've made those
criticisms for the past two years but
that was not the story when the model
report came out the story when the
Mellow report came out was indeed no
collusion and no evidence sufficient to
establish obstruction of justice in fact
I think that the molar reports attempted
definition of obstruction of justice as
I talked about last week as far as who
brought okay in just a second we're
gonna jump into the 2020 race because it
is starting to heat up first attention
American patriots this is your last
chance to win a gun that has
revolutionized the firearms world I've
teamed up with the u.s. ECA to give you
19 chances to win this very special gun
remember this is the 100% American based
organization that is dedicated to
bringing you industry-leading education
training and legal protection so which
gun are you gonna win here are some
hints one more time it's high-tech
polymer frame makes it lightweight
comfortable to conceal it is highly
customizable renowned for being durable
rugged and reliable even in the most
extreme environments in with its 15 plus
1 round capacity this gun will never
leave you hanging at the range or in a
self-defense situation if you want to
see this beautiful garden for yourself
all you have to do is text win - 87 - 2
- right now reveal what it is instantly
lock in your 19 free chances to win that
is win - 87 - - to win - 87 - 2 - it is
quick simple and free but you need to
hurry because the giveaway ends April
30th so text the word win - 87 - 2 -
right now lock in your 19 entries before
it is too late
text win - 8 7 - 2 - that is wi n 2 8 7
- 2 - and lock in your entries to win
this fantastic of firearm go check it
out right now also the u.s. CCA has all
sorts of great services there wonderful
organization you should be a member
regardless so text win - 87 - 2 -
alrighty so in just a second when we get
to the 2020 campaign which is heating up
Elizabeth Warren throwing random ideas
at the wall to see what sticks most of
them are exactly what that phrase would
suggest that crap and she'll see what
crap sticks to the wall we'll get to her
latest brilliant proposal from the
Native American princess in just one
second first head on over to daily wire
comm and you can subscribe to see the
rest of the show $9.99 a month brings
you the rest of the show live it brings
you on most weeks two additional hours
of the show a day this week because it
is Passover I'm only doing the podcast a
live radio show will be variously
performed
by the execrable Michel moles as well as
Jason rants from up in Seattle so have
pretty awesome guest host this week's
you're gonna want to check that out
anyway but normally you get two
additional hours of my stuff also you
get to be part of the mailbag also you
got our Sunday specials on Saturday we
have all sorts of goodies available for
you and when you spend $99 you get this
the very greatest and leftist ears
hundred call tumblers the sign of a man
of taste and propriety to have one of
these leftist ears hot or cold tumblers
you can have one it makes you smarter it
makes you wise or it makes you more
healthy none of those cleanse guaranteed
go check it out right now
leftist here's hot or cold tumbler and
an annual subscription cheaper than the
monthly subscribe over YouTube and
iTunes as well when you do that then you
can ensure that you get all of our free
material the downloads directly to you
please leave this review it always helps
we have the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so the 2020 race is heating
up Democrats are getting ready to attack
each other so we are about to enter the
most juicy portion of the 2020 race are
you excited I am because so far they've
been laying off of each other and it
started off like this in 2016 if you can
go back in your wayback machine all the
way back to mid 2015 all the Republicans
said were nice things about each other
oh how much Ruby I love the cruise and
how much Cruise loved Rubio and how much
both of them kind of liked Trump I mean
he was a populist sure and he didn't
really know a lot of things but he was a
shot in the arm was Trump and then as
the months went on the Long Knives came
out and the carving began and by the end
of it everybody looked like riffin
Bernardo after the fight scene in West
Side Story and it was just it was brutal
it was brutal well get ready because
it's gonna be fun this time among the
Democrats there are 20 candidates
fighting for scraps and apparently
another candidate just trying to get him
Seth Moulton from Massachusetts he's
probably gonna who's looking to lose his
primary race in Massachusetts he's
considered a slightly more moderate
Democrat but it's hilarious I mean there
are 1 million candidates they're all
struggling for attention and a lot of
the people who were supposed to be
top-tier simply have had failure to
launch top among those has of course
been senator Elizabeth Warren our Native
American princess who once wrote a
recipe for powwow Chow to demonstrate
her Native American bona fide ease that
powwow chow recipe was apparently a New
York chef based recipe for crab bisque a
traditional Cherokee disk about crabs
roaming the fruited Plains of Oklahoma
in any case Elizabeth Warren is trying
to jump out to the radical left she's
trying to out Bernie Bernie so good luck
with that here she was over the weekend
suggesting the president Trump must be
impeached the report is absolutely clear
that a foreign government attacked our
electoral system to help Donald Trump he
welcomed that help and then when it was
investigated by our own federal
authorities Donald Trump took multiple
steps to try to obstruct justice equal
justice under law no one is above the
law
and that includes the President of the
United States it is the constitutional
responsibility of Congress to follow
through on that I mean it's the
responsibility of Congress I was like
she knows she
we're gonna have to vote on this this is
one of the beautiful things about being
a Democrat in the Senate running for
president there are 90 of you and you
have a minority in the Senate so no
matter what you do you can vote for
Trump's impeachment get all the credit
and never have to actually live with the
consequences politically speaking
so Elizabeth Warren pushing for
impeachment she's trying to push to the
left of Bernie sander Sanderson's not
actually commented formally on
impeachment at this point so far as I am
aware and now she's rolling out another
proposal she rolls out a proposal every
day because she figures okay and at some
point some of these have got to make
some headlines I mean come on guys what
we have to do here to get some attention
I mean I already did a DNA test and you
just made fun of me so now I'm just
gonna roll out a proposal every single
day every single day it's like when my
sit her campaign is like when my son
wants a suite from the closet but
doesn't want to tell me so we have a
pantry in our house and what he will do
is he will stand directly outside the
pantry and then he will say
daddy open pantry and I'll say no what
do you want in there and he'll say
something and I'll say what is this
something say something and say what is
it and I'll say crackers I'll say you
don't want crackers and he'll say
squeezy no say you don't want squeezy
and then finally he will admit that did
his candy that he wants well that's
Elizabeth Warren and Elizabeth Warren
stands out there and she says I am
progressive like okay what do you mean
and just progressive like okay what do
you mean
and she's like free stuff free stuff for
everybody that's what I mean like all of
the reasonable nature of Elizabeth
Warren that existed in 2001-2002 short a
pretty good book called the to income
trap about the struggles of families to
get by and all this stuff
she used to be for school vouchers all
that has gone out the window all she's
in favor of now is free stuff she's
gonna out free Bernie Sanders so Bernie
Sanders has suggested free college
tuition Elizabeth Warren is gonna go
even further than Bernie Sanders is
gonna be amazing guys in a second I'll
tell you what so Elizabeth Warren is now
proposing the senator to try and get
attention she is now proposing to wipe
out Americans college debt completely
college debt forgiveness okay which
would actually be a violation of the
Constitution of the United States that
would be a full-on violation of the
takings clause the takings Clause
suggests that I cannot simply as the
government declare all private debts to
be null and void that would be me taking
something of value from you
just compensation not even for public
use that's for private use right you get
to keep the benefits and it's not going
to the government the benefit doesn't go
to the government eminent domain is the
government needs your house because
they're building a highway and so they
compensate you for the house
eminent domain really was not supposed
to be the government takes my house and
hands it to you because you are more
capable of paying higher taxes because
you're adding a second story on to the
house and certainly it's not the
government just feels like bulldozing
the house because the government feels
like bulldozing it for no reason well
that's what she is talking about right
here she's talking about a violation of
the takings Clause simply forgiving all
college debt now this is stupid in 1,000
ways in 1,000 ways let me read you what
her proposal is and then I'll explain
why this is so incredibly dumb and
counterproductive and doesn't fulfill
even what is something to do so she is
proposed to wipe out student debts and
tuition at public colleges she unveiled
on Monday her proposal for easing access
to higher education it would spend 1.25
trillion dollars over ten years to
eliminate up to $50,000 in student debt
with household incomes under $100,000 ok
first of all I will note this is already
a wealth redistribution that actually
favors people who are middle class or
wealthier because who do you think is
going to college it's mostly people who
are middle class or wealthier people who
have higher income potentials and higher
income trajectories so you're talking
effectively about taxing low income
people in favor of middle and high
income people she says she would allow
states to make public colleges tuition
free there are any states that do this
like University of Tennessee and she
wants to spend a hundred billion dollars
on expended Pell grants to defray more
non tuition expenses so she wants to
simply wipe out all of this college debt
her plan would scale back relief for
people with incomes above $100,000 and
would end it entirely at the $250,000
level she said her proposal would
benefit 95 percent of the 45 million
Americans carrying a student debt and
wipe it out for 75 percent of them she
said that this would stimulate the
economy by improving credit scores
that's so funny I love that so we're
going to eliminate debt that you're
unable to pay to improve your credit
score in other words we're going to game
the credit score system the credit score
system is I took out a debt now I have
to pay back that debt every time I pay
back that debt my credit score goes up
every time a debt collector is called my
credit score goes down herSolution what
if we just forgive the debt and then
that increases your credit score this is
the equivalent
when the city of Los Angeles decided
that South Central Los Angeles had too
much crime and if they just called it
South Los Angeles that would fix the
problem no the problem is you're not
paying your debts the problem is not
that you're your creditworthiness goes
up if we simply forgive your debts it's
insane and then she says this would
increase home buying great so the people
who are incapable of paying back at a
college debts we should definitely make
it super easy for them to take out home
loans maybe we could call them like I
know these aren't prime borrowers maybe
what we should just probably call them
subprime borrowers and what we could do
is have the government subsidized
subprime home loans to people who are
incapable of paying off their debts in
other ways and then we could grant them
these subprime home loans with
government subsidies and we could
incentivize private businesses by saying
that if those subprime home loans are
not paid back then the government will
bail you out it'll be totally fine I
feel like this would be a really good
plan for fixing the mortgage system
subprime home loans provided by the
government for people who are not credit
worthy what could go wrong nothing
probably everything will be fine guys
everything will be fine and then she
says this will ease small business
formation if you want to East small
business formation let me make you a
recommendation instead of incentivizing
lenders to give money to people to go to
college to major and lesbian dance
Theory instead we should be
incentivizing lenders to lend money to
people who are starting businesses you
know one way to do this stop insisting
that everyone who is smart has to go to
college stop insisting that the pathway
to success in the United States is to go
major in Maya Angelou's poetry at JUCO
that is not correct she also wants to
cut off federal money from for-profit
colleges she says those enrich
themselves while targeting lower-income
students targeting lower-income students
you know how you know how hard Harvard
is trying to get low-income students in
there kicking Asians out for no reason
to get low-income students in Harvard
she says that private colleges are the
problem no you want to know why the cost
of tuition is so high because of
publicly sponsored tuition that's why
the cost is high every area where the
government subsidizes prices go up this
is true in health care it is true in
tuition every time the government gives
you free money people increase the
prices on the thing that you are now
buying why because there's more money in
circulation
you don't okay so her proposal makes no
sense if you actually wanted to fix all
of this you have
eliminate federal involvement in student
loans and fewer people go to college and
that would be a good thing because not
everyone needs to go to college instead
we would have apprenticeships people who
are skipping college to apprentice
themselves in a business where they get
to learn a skill set what colleges are
good for I've said this for years what
colleges are good for is two things
they're fundamentally a sorting
mechanism so if you went to Harvard we
assume you're smarter than someone who
went to JUCO and - they create a social
fabric of friends with whom you can
correspond and get jobs that's what
college is for well by vastly broadening
the number of people going to college
and creating affirmative action programs
that's Hugh the system and what you're
actually doing is eliminating both of
the actual effective methods of
increasing income mobility inside
colleges you're getting rid of the of
the sorting factor on the one hand and
on the other hand you are also getting
rid of the air Sat social fabric because
you don't create a social fabric at JUCO
those are not people you associate with
the rest of your life this really only
applies to elite colleges that doesn't
exist sending somebody to a low level
state school with free tuition to major
in whatever they please is not going to
materially better their lives
that's silly talk so Elizabeth Warren is
proposing all of this stuff Kevin
Williamson laid this out a while back in
a piece that he wrote for National
Review a three-step plan actually he
wrote this a couple of days ago he said
here's a three-part plan for doing
something practical one the federal
government should stop making college
loans itself and cease guaranteeing any
such loans why because that would force
banks to actually try to determine
whether a loan was going to be paid back
based on the major I could take a loan
for law school why because I was going
to be a lawyer
which meant I was a good bet the
collateral was me to my to step two it
should prohibit educational lending by
federally regulated financial
institutions or require the application
of ordinary credit standards and ever in
any private educational lending treating
the student as the main credit risk in
the same way that you would a mortgage
and three it should make student loans
at dischargeable in ordinary bankruptcy
procedures so this would put the risk on
the banks the banks would have to make
an actual decision as to whether people
should get a loan or should not get a
loan based on whether they think the
person's gonna be able to pay the thing
back or not and this makes sense but
Elizabeth Warren is talking about makes
no sense fortunately being in the 2020
Democratic Party means never having to
say anything sensible
you don't have to say anything just have
to promise a lot of free stuff so
Elizabeth Warren gonna track this out
and hope that this sticks as well
unlikely unlikely but who the hell knows
alrighty time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like over the holiday I reread a
book by journal Trotter who is an MIT
physicist at MIT educated physicist
called the science of God the
convergence of science scientific and
biblical wisdom it's really interesting
stuff perfectly appropriate for both
Easter and Passover it's really good
it's all about how the book of Genesis
can be read in a way that makes room for
science which is something that I'm very
much in favor of and his take
particularly on how the six days of
creation match up with the timeline for
creation that is expressed via science
is really fascinating the essential
thesis is that there is a universal
background clock of the universe that is
being used up until the creation of man
and then 24 earth hours corresponds to a
certain number of background radiation
wavelengths in the universe blackbody
radiation wavelengths in the universe
for 24 hours within the creation
timeframe within the Big Bang timeframe
so to get a little bit more complex on
that and to in simplify actually you
have to read the book go check it out
the science of God by Gerald Schroeder
great religious and scientific reading
it really is pretty cool stuff okay time
for a bevy of things that I hate a
cornucopia of things that I hate all
right so thing that I hate number one
there is a story in what is this the UK
the UK Daily Mail gay transgender man
tells story of giving birth okay so it
says not only women feel broody
transgender man reveals he was desperate
to have a child before he went through a
total loss of self as he became pregnant
with his baby okay let me explain this
person is not female I mean this person
is not male this is not a male giving
birth if a male gave birth do you have
any idea how bad that would hurt we have
a urethra you do not have a birth canal
your try pushing a 10-pound baby through
a urethra you will die
okay this is not where's that baby
coming from if you're Jenna if you are
agent if you are a male like a genetic
biological male
you can't poop out the baby and you
can't pee out the baby there's no way to
get the baby out also you have no uterus
so there's no place for the baby to grow
so biology suggests that this is fact
not a gay male who had a baby because
that's silly this is actually a genetic
female who had a baby I love this
Freddie McConnell 30 is a gay
transgender man who gave birth to a baby
boy no Freddie McConnell is a woman a
woman who had a surgery who gave birth
to a baby I like that he say that she
because this is a genetic female she is
that now a gay transgender man which
means a woman who is attracted to men
but had a surgery that makes more sense
than whatever the hell this mishmash
word salad that you've created here a
film of his experience of pregnancy will
premiere at the Tribeca Film Festival
his mother described her fears for her
son as he embarked on the pregnancy he
spent most of the nine months who's
pregnant with his son in deal Kent's Wow
spectacular stuff here's a little bit of
this magical film about a female having
a baby but this female has a beard
because of hormone treatments and
because of breast removal so wonderful
stuff so hormone treatment breast
removal genetic female this is not
shocking this is just a person who did
something to her body first by the
testosterone quite quickly I was being
read as male with time it's not about
more male because more valid it's just
this is me I've always wanted to have
kids one day not only women feel broody
I'm
have my own baby when I will be dad I
love being pregnant everyone should
experience such a thing especially men
this is not a man everyone to experience
being pregnant especially men he this is
not a man this is a woman okay and you
can you can make the woman look like a
man but that is still a woman and it's
not only women who feel broody you are a
woman no one is suggesting only women
feel broody but you happen to be one you
happen to be a woman the unbelievable
stupidity of a media that refuses to
objectively cover facts of biology is
insane and by logic by biology is
certainly implicated when we are talking
about you know biological things like
giving birth like the biological organs
necessary to the birth giving how do you
suggest the gender is the thing on the
table when what we are really talking
about here is a pure biological process
right we'd all be shocked if we read a
story about a man having a period
because that's impossible a man does not
have a period by definition but the
media will repeat this crap like no
problem it's just insane so why do I get
upset about this because I don't like
being lied to because I think that this
is a wrecked attempt to undermine both
science and objective truth and I don't
care what your interior feelings are
your body tells the story your uterus
developed a baby and then you push that
baby through a birth canal ending in a
vagina that is what happened here that
means that that you are a genetic female
my goodness so that's crazy towns okay
other stuff that I that the media
coverage is crazy
okay the other stuff that I hate today
so apparently there's a story that
Mexican troops actually drew weapons on
American soldiers on the US side of the
American border is according to the
Washington Examiner armed Mexican troops
disarmed two US soldiers while they were
on the American side of the border US
defense officials have said us Northern
Command said in a statement that five to
six million Mexicans sorry five to six
Mexican military personnel questioned
two US Army soldiers over five to six
million we have an invasion on our hands
five to six Mexican military personnel
questioned two US Army soldiers who were
conducting border support operations
this month the US soldiers were in an
unmarked Customs and Border Protection
vehicle near the southwest border near
Clint Texas officials confirm the
Mexican troops were armed with what
seemed to be rifles they raised their
weapons when they saw the two US
soldiers and then took a pistol from one
and put it on the CPB vehicle according
to officials talking to CNN the two
Americans obliged in an attempt to
de-escalate a potentially
volatile situation throughout the
incident the US soldiers followed all
established procedures and protocols the
statement said the two US troops were on
the south side of the security perimeter
but north of the Rio Grande and those
were in the United States on the
American side of the border Pentagon and
department of homeland security
officials demanded an explanation from
the Mexican government an inquiry by CPB
and TOC revealed that the Mexican
military members believed that the US
Army soldiers were south of the border
though they were south of the border
fence u.s. soldiers remained in u.s.
territory north of the actual border
this looks like confusion more than
anything else but the fact that this
confusion almost led to a violent
incident is definitely on the Mexican
government which would be spending a lot
more of its resources prohibiting people
from moving across the American border
on mass we have hundreds of thousands of
people descending on the American border
now every month that's a disaster area
the Mexican government should obviously
be helping more with the fact that we
have a failed state on our southern
border is a disaster area nobody seems
to want to face up to because it would
actually there's a better case for
American intervention in Mexico frankly
than there is for American intervention
in Syria ones on our border and is
creating a human catastrophe in which
the drug cartels are in control of large
swaths of the territory is leading to
not only humanitarian problems but
actual direct impact on America's
southern border maybe a wall solves that
maybe a wall doesn't but what we're
watching in Mexico is is really a
continuing problem okay we will be back
here tomorrow as they say there's two
more hours of the show but I'm not
hosting them later today because it's
Passover and I want to take a little bit
of time off and damn it I deserve it
come on okay so we're gonna do that
you'll see you here tomorrow so enjoy
the rest of your day and if you can
enjoy Michael moles I know it's
difficult we'll see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
Islamic terrorists in Sri Lanka murdered
290 Catholics on Easter Sunday around
the world churches have become the
number one target for attacks we will
explore lies and ignorance in our post
Christian society fellow Easter
worshippers check it out at daily wire
calm